oh my god Amana last night was so much
fun oh my god yeah we should do that
we're all set guys were crazy though Oh
what guys my guys they're my friends
yeah they were like no no no for real
what guy I just told you guys are my
friends
no there's no friendship between guys
and girls that's not possible right oh
okay so you don't have any girlfriends
that's different yeah it's different
because you're in their dm's every day
did you go through my phone it was
unlost and why are you sending eggplant
emoji she's reaching oh okay vegan it's
a recipe what are you saying brother is
your neighbor minions like
overprotective this is your habitat you
need to stick up for yourself I don't
even know what he's doing back there
can't let a man tell you what to do is
for your brother come on girl you are on
what menu to go over there you stay here
I'm gonna go over there and pick up for
you do that girl woman power yeah I got
you and doesn't do this
haha right oh I see you're going to
seduce him into a chair called lips yes
by him by Amhara
that's an interesting tackle yeah that's
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey babes
what are you doing you know what I don't
feel that well late way too much of your
leftovers hey how was it I can't hear a
word baby gonna move the dye out of you
what are you doing I'm gonna see you
come on what what is this open your
bottle baby you're beautiful no matter
what okay I love you hmm yes are you
sure yeah hey guys me amanda cerny thank
you so much for watching my surrogates
and liking and commenting i literally
read every single one of them so thank
you guys teen journey is growing and I
love it
I want to involve you guys even more so
what I'm doing now is I'm taking
surrogate suggestion ideas that ain't
you just comment below any good ideas
that you have from me and if I decide to
choose your idea I will shout you out in
my next journey skate youtube video so
keep the comments coming and you know it
could be you love you guys and I'll see
you next week what this is